I'm going to make sure this year we
develop the best leaders that the entire
industries ever seen all across the
board quality of business character
values delivery keeping your word
improving protecting each other and not
playing games and manipulative games
just so I can beat this other guy all of
us need to improve because if one day
someone's going to lead this army and
I'm not here anymore
I need you I'm top you don't want to
talk I'm talking to you not talking
talking to you right there you yeah I'm
talking to you I need you to improve you
listen to me I need you to improve I
need you to improve I think a world of
you I think a world of you I think a
world of you any selfish dreams that you
have will become a reality I can promise
you that if you do your part can become
a reality one day you're gonna have a
garage filled with a $400,000
Lamborghinis and $50,000 watches you've
got the stuff economy you've gotta get
it because you got to get it we're
looking at a seven million dollar home
right now you gotta go get it
but that's not the point you're gonna
feel like a billion bucks
not even a million bucks many of you
feel like a million bucks right now you
are a million bucks right you'll feel
priceless when you look at yourself in
the mirror and without you making any
effort you know tens of thousands of
people feel like they can follow your
word because they trust the decisions
you make even if it's a tougher one at
times just for the betterment for
everybody see I strive to do that that's
what I strive to do because at the end
of the day when I look at my wife's face
it matters to me
when I look at my kids faces the three
of them it matters to me to come through
for them when I go see my dad it matters
to me
when I talk to my sister my mother my
brother-in-law my nephew my niece it
matters to me
and when I see your faces when I see at
conventions it matters to me few dreams
become a reality but I do know you need
to upgrade you need to improve and you
can do it and we will do our part where
you get a do your part and as we do that
I promise you the world is ours we're
going to keep our promises we've got to
do a part you commit to that part I'm
committed to already the experiences are
going to be strange
that's so much fun you have so much of a
blast so much fun so I'm gonna do so
many things that will look back and say
man it is ten thousand people combined
pocketless I've already done think about
what I just said to you ten thousand
people's buckets this combined you've
done we're gonna do that you don't do
that you can be part of it
[Music]
you